estamos hablando de número uno del mundo
el serbio dio covid Cómo le fue
bueno era el número uno de los mundo
ahora es el número tres aspirando a
volver a a tener de nuevo ese título y
le fue bastante bien A pesar de que le
tocó muy duro en este partido ante el
español Alejandro dávido foquina el
español que lo puso contra las cuerdas
tal vez el mejor partido que hemos visto
por ahora en esta edición de Roland
garros un partido como les decía
complicado para el serbio siete seis
siete seis Ya seis dos el español ya que
tal vez entre la frustración y el
cansancio pues ya soltó un poco y y dejó
escapar finalmente ya ese último tercer
set pero un muy buen partido el que se
vivió aquí se terminó hace pocos
instantes y bueno el público que quería
de todas maneras que sea pues se fueron
muchísimo más largo este partido Pero
bueno fueron más de tres horas de juego
y a pesar de que David hubiera podido
llevarse al menos uno de estos sets
bueno se notó que le falta todavía esa
brillantez ese genio que tiene Novak
Djokovic y por eso pues ha sido el
jugador que ha sido y tiene la carrera
que tiene hablemos ahora Natalia del
cuadro femenino ganó sabalenka pero
perdió pégula
Así es pues ha sido el día donde han
caído dos cabezas de serie usted lo
decía bien pegula que perdió ante la
belga Elizabeth pero también andrey
rubleza cayó bajo manosa italianas las
de Lorenzo y efectivamente sabalenca La
número dos que es una de las firmes
aspirantes no solamente a quedarse aquí
con el torneo por el parte de de en la
parte del cuadro femenino sino también
que aspira a hacer la número uno del
mundo pues ella anda aquí Como pez en el
agua igual que daría casequina ambas
ganaron sus partidos en tan solo dos
sets sin mayores esfuerzos Así que las
cosas van avanzando muy bien y esperamos
ahora dos partidazos que se vienen ya en
esta tarde noche aquí en París el de
Diego
cinco y también el último partido de la
noche que será entre Carlos Alcaraz y el
canadiense Dennis Este es un duelo
inédito el que veremos aquí en París
esta